well Joe Biden insulting even more
voters his latest attack being compared
to Hillary Clinton's 2016 deplorable z'
comment take a look do we really think
this as good as we can be as a nation I
don't think the vast majority people
think that they're probably anywhere
from 10 to 15 percent the people out
there they're just not very good people
but that's not who we are
the vast majority people are decent we
have to appeal to that and we have to
unite people bring them together so Greg
I'm wondering exactly who he's talking
about especially given the events of the
last week he's absolutely he's a comic
genius the fact that he talks about we
really need to unite people except 30 to
40 million people that I just said
aren't worth having around I'd like to
know who he's talking about are they all
white people are they male or they
female are they handicapped are children
part of it this remember this is some
this is the same guy who decides how
black you are after putting enough
blacks behind bars the worst part he's
just an appeaser and he's a pisser too
the hard left because he likes being in
power like I said this dissent is
divisive Mnet's keeps people like Joe
Biden safe in power if he's you know the
next riot and he's president he'll be in
his sunglasses and his aviator jacket
throwing the first ceremonial brick
don't think he need all the votes that
he needs I mean he needs as many voters
as possible doesn't he yeah we're Katie
why would you think that he doesn't want
votes I mean it I don't know who he's
talking about well he said they're not
good people he just he didn't say who
they were and so that's what Greg was
talking about I mean to my mind I think
politicians shouldn't be pundits you
know I mean when they try to categorize
an opponent's base if that's what he was
doing I think they make mistakes they
get themselves in trouble so to my mind
it stirs up the opponent's base right I
mean you can imagine that
that soundbites going to be repeated in
the Trump echo chamber for days to come
and say oh it's about Trump people but
he didn't say that so to my mind you
know it's not going to change any votes
pro or con I don't think anybody's going
to necessarily say I'm going to vote
that way because of this statement but
you know some people will try to exploit
it yes you're at fault
it's the people who pound yaza pounds
the bouncers the pouncing has commenced
Jesse yes Joe Biden is dead wrong I
think it's probably around 20 to 25% of
the population that it's much higher
than 10 to 15 percent and you know is
this a scandal no if Trump said it would
it be a scandal yes
am i that outraged about it I tried to
be I spent all day trying to work up
some real outrage over this comment I
just couldn't deliver it I'm sorry
because against the backdrop of whole
neighborhood's being burned to a crisp
and having people pulled out of their
big rigs and knock me unconscious I'm
not that worried about what Joe Biden
says on a podcast or a live stream what
I'm really concerned about is what Joe
Biden does and what Donald Trump does
and this is how the elections going to
be they're going to be judged on action
and who's going to be a man of action
and who's all talk and I think we know
who's up so Martha it seems like a lot
of what Joe Biden said is says it's kind
of baked into the cake so to speak about
how people feel about him well you know
I mean I'm just kind of laughing a
little bit here because I wasn't sure
who he was talking about either and as
we often find with some things that the
former vice president says it's awfully
hard to figure out exactly what he was
talking about and I and I think that
that has led to some confusion with this
comment you know like my colleagues here
I I looked it over a couple times I read
it that I'm trying to figure out was he
referring to maybe the people who were
committing violence during these during
the protests he
was he separating them out 10-15 percent
and I thought well if he's just talking
about the country I have to agree with
Jessie there's probably a larger number
than that that you could say might fall
into the group of you know people that
you wouldn't necessarily want to want to
hang out with or you don't think are
good nice people and you know I guess
for everybody that number that the
people that you would be directing that
I would be a different group so I think
it was a confusing statement I agree
with Jessie that it is it doesn't really
amount to one of the things that I think
is it's very clarifying about this
moment but between the virus and you
know watching that the uncredible
violence and unrest that we've seen in
the wake of the killing of George Floyd
is that it's very it makes you not sweat
the small stuff and I think this falls
in that category I think Joe Biden is
trying to register he's trying to say
stuff that sticks and matters but I
think he's having a hard time yep
that's for sure hey that's pretty
evident all right coming up next yes
Greg I just want to make a point that
there is something important to be about
this the fact that we Trump criticizes
it's an individual it's always an
individual that with the Democrats it's
always groups mm-hmm yeah well you're
pouncing right now so we're going to
move on from that